foreign
good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through grants from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data seminar
Series has focused on the use of data
science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes within the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we will enjoy
presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues promises opportunities
and hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these include
delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle has just
been extended to January January 31st
and so we encourage Junior faculty
members who are working in areas such as
infectious diseases epidemiology
clinical medicine population Health as
well as data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program with
characterizing the secondary health
effects of covid-19 necessitates unique
quantitative approaches but also new
multi-disciplinary collaborations
participants selected for the biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
Leverage The presentations like you're
going to hear today as vital material in
their culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held
at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr
foreign associate professor of the
Department of industrial and systems
engineering at Virginia Tech
Naveed earned his PhD in public policy
and working in systems Dynamics from the
State University of New York at Albany
in 2011. he holds a masters of Business
Administration and management from
Sharif University of Technology
mechanical engineering also from Sharif
University and prior to joining Virginia
Tech he was a postdoctoral researcher at
MIT in the environmental systems or
Engineering Systems division excuse me
navid's research interests includes
systems level thinking and systems
Dynamics modeling of complex social
systems with applications in health
policy his work includes modeling the
spread of infectious diseases in his
covid-19 related research papers have
appeared in various journals such as the
Lancet bio bioscience plus computational
biology and he has received considerable
media attention by The Washington Post
the New York Times the BBC and Le Monde
his research has been supported by
several Federal organizations such as
the NIH the Department of Defense and
the National Science Foundation fun fact
about navis even Joe always watching
soccer and is a fan of persepolis
football club and team melee and he ran
his first half marathon at the age of
44. so there is hope for us all so thank
you Navid and continuing with the
2022-2023 biomedical data science uh
seminar series theme navi's lecture
today is entitled enhancing long-term
forecasting learning from covid-19
models and he is going to describe for
us that while much of the effort has
gone into building predictive models
um of the covid-19 pandemic some have
argued that early exponential growth
combined with this the stochastic nature
of epidemics makes long-term prediction
of contagion trajectories next to
Impossible and he's going to demonstrate
two complementary studies to assess
model features which support better
long-term predictions he's going to
describe how he leverages diverse models
contributing to
um the CDC repository of covid-19 and US
USA death projections to identify
factors associated with increasing the
predictability and accuracy across
different projection Horizons he's then
going to introduce a very simple model
which incorporates these features and
offers informative predictions as far as
20 weeks ahead with accuracy comparable
to the best models in the CDC data set
and he is going to argue that long-term
predictive power of multi-wave covid-19
trajectories is capturing behavioral
responses balancing feedbacks where
perceived risk and death continuously
changes transmission rates throughout
the adoption and relaxation of various
non-pharmaceutical interventions as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you are watching on YouTube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected 22 to 2022 2023
biomedical science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions via the chat
feature in their Zoom sessions I will
synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome Navid we are very much
looking forward to hearing what you have
to tell us
thank you very much for the generous
introduction it's a great pleasure to be
in this group and present this work uh
so this work is about
um pandemic forecasting and it is a
collaborative work my co-authors are
hajjiram on that from MIT and ranshu
from University of Connecticut our works
have been recently funded by the NSF and
in division of mathematical sciences and
social and economic Sciences
so we have been all dealing with the
problem of covid-19 and we can easily
remember how things have evolved in the
past three years there have been many
puzzling questions and research has been
done you know different research
projects to uncover those and some of
the kind of questions that quickly comes
to our mind are about
um estimation of cases that we have in
terms of covid-19 estimating how many
people have died you know providing more
accurate estimations then another layer
of questions are about policies how What
policies help to better contain the
disease and these policy questions comes
up at the government level at
organizations level you know many of you
in universities uh probably your
universities have been thinking about
how to help keep students safe
or even at the individuals you know many
of us have been thinking what type of
actions help to keep our family safer
and then other questions about scenarios
things that are exogenous and may
influence the spread of a disease such
as changing the weather
but one
other another question which is related
to the other ones is about forecasting
can we offer a better short-term and
long-term forecasting of the spirit of
the disease and this is the main focus
of this presentation but it is also
related to the other questions too why
do we care about forecasting actually
forecasting has been always one of the
concerns that we have had for making
better decisions in our society just
when you can forecast about things that
are going to happen for your
organization for your country you can be
more proactive so there is a strong
reason that forecasting matters makes
you smarter
in terms of pandemic it is unavoidable
you know we have to forecast you know we
we have emergency measures in place we
want to make a better plan about
resource allocations and make it more
efficient allocation of resources so we
want to know how the how the pandemic
will look like a few a month ahead and
and and be prepared for that
in terms of Hospital capacity we like to
be prepared for that but even at the
individual level you know wedding plans
or you know attending conferences in
person or online these are things that
come up and they are connected to
forecasting so whether or not you are
developing a formal model for
forecasting you at the end you know you
you have to predict or
um kind of have some kind of you know
expectations about how the disease will
go on to make better decisions and if
you don't have models many times we end
up using our own mental models our best
guesses about how the future will evolve
but there are several problems about
pandemic forecasting and uh you know
just looking back it feels like you know
um
we had models that predicted
um cases that were far from reality and
far from things that emerged you know we
had at in the in two extreme conditions
too I mean we had models that predicted
that there will be millions of death in
just a few months just at the beginning
of the pandemic and there were also
models that predicted that by May 2020
everything will end and we'll be back to
normal life and none of these happen so
apparently pandemic forecasting was very
difficult as a result some of these
Scholars have suggested that just this
is probably impossible or very hard to
do it is because of always is not
necessarily because of lack of data but
it's just the nature of
um exponential growth that you see in
these situations with a little bit
um deviation at the beginning you end up
with a different trajectory so maybe
that's the reason that
is hard to do you ask a little bit
different questions that you know if we
can just look at a sample of models
about covid-19 and explore which ones
are doing better and what model features
makes them better models maybe we can
bring insights into better developing
better forecasting models maybe we can
have better models better use of data to
provide a better long-term pandemic
many of you are aware of this
fundamental building block of many
um epidemic models which is seir model
it goes back to 100 years ago and the
basic logic is that when you want to
model the spirit of the disease you
divide the population to specific groups
susceptibles expose infected and then
removed and then you have different
feedback loops but especially the one
that infected individuals resulting more
exposure and then with this positive
feedback look you end up
um having it you know more and more
spread of the disease and then you know
at some point you run out of
susceptibles and then that's where the
um the Finish we are finished with it
with the epidemic but
when you simulate these models you
usually have two different modes of
behavior one of them is exponential
growth and then saturation is like an
s-shaped curve I mean obviously with
different slopes but the the figure look
um very similar at least qualitatively
the other mode is that you know
depending the pandemic doesn't emerge
and at the beginning with the you know R
naught of less than one you just never
um have rise in cases so there are two
different modes of behavior if you look
at Active cases you see one kind of um
pumped in number of cases and then it
goes down and we are done
there are several uh extension to this
model obviously in the past 100 years
and these extensions are in different
directions especially in
increasing the number of carbon partners
and those kind of boxes that you see in
the picture you know what if we divide
are infected to asymptomatic versus
symptomatic you know what if we um add
you know another uh stock variable for
people who are in hospital and so on so
there are different directions and but
there are also limitations to these
models you know and people have been
dealing with that so these are the
common behaviors that you see on the
left hand and then the if you look at
the data the data looks like looks
differently this is data from the United
States and as you see until you know
October 2021 it is not just one you know
bell-shaped here in terms of cases but
you see oscillation oscillation in cases
oscillation in confirmed cases
oscillation confirmed death and even not
a constant test coverage number of
people that are tested are diff are
changing over time and that also
influences
how many confirmed cases you have so not
a regular essay curve not a bell-shaped
curve oscillatory patterns in data and
change in observations over time this is
not just us you look at all around the
world and you see different sorts of
behavior again you know oscillation
exists in many parts of the world
but you know with different frequency or
a period of oscillation and different
magnitude of oscillations all these and
graphs are normalized to the population
so you can actually compare uh the
y-axis to and as you see you know in the
in Peru and Chile we have big numbers
for daily cases and death then you know
we end up with South Korea and New
Zealand with lower number of cases per
million of population so you have a
range of behaviors and it is a little
bit too much to expect from scr models
to predict and and produce all these
branches of behavior
so what can be done to have a better
model for to have a better forecast
this is our study design so we take
advantage of this data set that exists
in CDC so CDC in April 2020 so early in
the pandemic created this fantastic
forecast hop which many modelers
submitted their projections in that Hub
and on a weekly basis so every week
and very experienced modelers very good
teams we're submitting their projections
their model based projections about how
many cases or how many deaths we will
have in the next weeks on a weekly basis
so you would predict predict next week
that two weeks later that three weeks
later then so some time Horizon and you
would submit to this forecast also
there's this huge data set there
based on how models have been
broadcasting and we focused on models
that forecast death
there were 61 models that they were
providing forecast and it is not just
National level actually many of them
were for specific locations and 57 kind
of specific location in the US you can
recognize that there were projections
for them on a weekly basis and we picked
this one year period which was around
the time that we started this research
and the and these models you know some
of them were forecasting like one to
four weeks ahead and some of them were
providing a long European forecasting
which was interesting so you are dealing
with a huge number of data points in
terms of forecasts about half a million
data parts that are coming from these 60
models for very for a big sample of
regions not just with one sample
and over a year so it's not just one
bumping number of cases but capturing
the oscillation so there is this data
and we thought that okay we can start by
studying the approaches of that these
modelers have used in their models look
at their Reports look at the articles
that are coming out of this and analyze
if there is association between model
architecture assumptions that exist in
the model
approaches that these modelers have
taken and then accuracy of the forecast
you know remember that that half a
million data points that we have time
has passed and we actually have now the
correct value of Def so we can calculate
the error in those predictions and see
if there is any association between
model architecture or p60 models and how
accurately have been in their forecast
and then if we can extract the main
insights and build a simple model we can
kind of compare and validate that model
using this analysis
model categories that we recognize early
on by looking at these very these four
big groups you may have mechanistic
compartments on model it's very similar
to the slide that you saw at the
beginning so it follows the logic of
using compartments stocks for how people
are divided into a different population
you often use differential equation to
formulate those models
another category is non-mechanistic
models which has been growing especially
recently with machine learning
techniques regression techniques so the
idea is that you're not simulating the
mechanics of how the disease spreads
many times you have a black box model
that has inputs and outputs so the goal
is to have a better prediction of from
for those outputs and and improve your
model over time
you have a third category which is
Ensemble models many modelers have
multiple models
and which can be mechanistic or
non-mechanistic and just they combine
the results either they look at the mean
of
forecasts or median forecast and use
that as the output of their forecasted
so technically Ensemble models are also
kind of combination of mechanistic and
non-mechanistic models the other fourth
category others and we were hoping to
see more agent-based models there but it
turned out that there were only two
agent-based models and they didn't
continue projecting I'm assuming that
that's because of the high computational
expensiveness of these type of models in
simple words it takes time to project
and if you want to submit your
projections on a weekly base probably
it's not that feasible
we went through all the documents that
exist in these models and not all models
are well documented so there is a
variation in terms of how documents are
provided but we looked for what are the
variables that you're considering your
model what are their approaches for
using
data in your model is the data and input
to the model or it is used for model
calibration and can be you know fixing
model with the data
and what are the outputs of these models
are they projecting death cases and into
what time Horizon they are considering
their forecast
one important question was that how
transmission intensity or reproduction
number is modeled here you know
sometimes people use simplistic
assumptions and you with a constant
number but sometimes you have a more
advanced
um approach and try to model it
explicitly or implicitly in the model
and try to kind of predict how
transmission is going to change over
time especially for the future
transmission it becomes important that
are we assuming that from now on the
disease will have the same reproduction
number or is going to change as people's
behavior changes
finally stage we're sending is is the
idea that
um
how they are dealing with errors in
their estimations and in their
calibrations there are Advanced methods
like common filtering that we try to
filter for all the noises that you have
in your
um in your simulation to have better
estimations of your parametrics so how
advanced are these calibration methods
in terms of Mobility there was uh this
interesting Trend in in models that many
try to actually include that has inputs
to their model so it is a representation
of human behavior so how that was done
in the model that was a question that we
dealt with you know are they modeling
how people change their Mobility or we
are using data and data goes as an input
to the model rather than having a having
Mobility as a function of other state
variables
in addition you know we gathered data
about modelers affiliation your
disciplinary and where they're coming
you know is it from industry or Academia
and the availability of technical
documents and so on you looked at other
factors specifically in each group of
modeling for example in mechanistic
models that have you know the ones that
had enough documentation you can look at
the the level to which these models are
are you know provide a detailed
representation of the spread of the
disease is that just three state
variable sir or suir or it is way more
detailed are they like age structures or
included in those models or no they are
all considered
um kind of an average and aggregate
and you know are they considering
weather impacts in their mechanistic
models similar questions were raised
about non-mechanistic models you know
what is the approach again is that a
regression model is that a machine
learning model
and the same you know do they consider
weather impact and Ensemble model you
know which type of models they have
included so these are all coding so
according this coding it is more like a
qualitative work that you go through all
the documents and analyze it and see how
they have done the job and the
quantitative part was about analyzing
the forecast errors and kind of finding
you know how the errors are emerging and
then finding associations between what
you are seeing in a model structure and
the amount of error that they have had
in their projections
our first round of results is just
analysis of these these models
first let's look at the distribution of
the models this is how you see in
different categories
mechanistic models
are kind of the majority of the models
that we see in this in this sample
non-mechanistic models they're actually
producing you know a kind of a
considerable fraction of the models
about 38 of the model is very
non-mechanistic and Ensemble model is
around like 12 percent of the models
they're Ensemble models under the
category of mechanistic models you can
divide the models into different groups
we divided them to
compartments all with Stage resetting
and without a stage resetting and agent
based model so agent-based models are
actually individual and as I said there
are only two models in that category and
they didn't continue projecting after a
while but in compartmental models we had
models that had more sophisticated
methods of dealing with noise in data
and trying to kind of filter for those
noise and the ones that kind of took you
a more simplestic approach so these are
categories of models that we observed
after coding the data then we plot the
error that we see in their projections
B and x-axis here is prediction Horizon
so week one is the error that you're
producing when you are projecting next
week
um
week two is amount of error that you're
producing when you're projecting week
two and uh y-axis here is the relative
error so it's not absolute error but we
are comparing the error that each of the
category of these models have with a
constant model so that's our Baseline
and constant model was is the simplest
model that you can have as a naive model
it the Assumption in a constant model is
that whatever death is today depth of
code is today that's going to continue
for 14 weeks so we are not changing the
numbers we are just going with whatever
today is so that's the simplest model
that you can have and we pick that and
compare the errors that you get from
each of these categories with that
constant model
let's just focus on red line and blue
line and the red line is those
non-mechanistic models like regression
models machine learning models and the
blue line are those compartmental models
that are differential equations like SAR
models but with no stage resetting
as you see in short term Redline is
doing better lower error but in long
term blue line is doing better so it
appears that carefitting approaches in
the red line are good at providing
short-term predictions but probably they
are overfitting and in long term you're
getting
lots of error in our projections
in contrast the blue line was doing bad
in short term but in long term because
it was probably capturing the mechanics
of the spread of the disease it had
limited
um kind of future projections and it was
providing some more insights about
future projections but what was better
than all of these were compartmental
models that had a stage resetting too so
either that's about stage resetting so
the benefits of dealing with noises in
data and kind of trying to filter them
or just people who were doing these type
of filtering techniques they were
actually better modelers and their
models ended up having lower errors over
the long range too these are average of
errors that you get from each these
categories so we did lots of regression
analysis and and all these results and
insights are robust and um
and a few other things that you know you
would find is that
um
well not no academic models are barely
better if at all from non-academic
models and you know there are like a few
things for example you know that
constant model wasn't doing that bad you
know when you compare with some of these
groups and there's a reason for that I
will discuss why in long term you're
you're getting some benefits from that
naive assumption that will have the same
level of death in the future but these
are the first layer of results that you
get from this analysis and if I want to
list a few other insights that we got
after kind of analyzing all these models
in at the individual level is that first
in long-term projections mechanic
mechanistic models we're performing
better than non-mechanistic models or
care fitting models so that was obvious
in the previous graph the second point
was that the models that captured
transmission rate they did a better
forecast you know change in transmission
rate so models that are modeling or
considering the fact that reproduction
number or the speed of spread of the
disease may change in the future as
human behavior changes they are doing a
better job in their forecast the ones
that are assuming whatever the
transmission rate is today that's how
things will evolve in the future this is
how the virus is behaving they are doing
a worse projection in the future so that
was one of the interesting things that
we found one of these models were
actually endogenously modeling
transmission rate the logic was simple
the models were assuming that if death
rate per million you know passes some
threshold
the government is going to have more
lockdown measures or similar measures
which will decrease transmission rate so
they had built this assumption for their
future projection as they were
projecting they had this mechanism in
their model that your death rate is
going to increase in this model there
will be some intervention by government
future to decrease that by decreasing
transmission
this is endogenously modeling and
transmission rate a few good models
included weather impact and stator
setting looks like helpful based on the
past graph
so the question is that
um so these are associations right like
how good really they are can we do a
little experiment and see you know kind
of you know control things and see are
they really improving in the um benefits
that you get from forecast
so let's just build the simplest model
that you can have and only include these
uh four features and see if that model
does any better
so we start with the simplest possible
model is scir and we add a behavioral
feedback loop to that which captures
endogenous change in transmission rate
if cases and death increases you're
assuming that people's risk perception
will increase and that means that they
will involve they will do some kind of
measures they will definitely involved
in some preventive measures that will
decrease Transmission in future and as
death declines they will feel more
relaxed and they will go more outside
which can increase the transmission rate
the statory setting is simple I will
talk about that and impact of bitter is
was it published paper by our team when
we just included that effect marginal
effect on our projection to see how how
much that really helps and we exclude
many other important factors that one
should not exclude when they are doing a
forecasting job and the reason is that
we want to keep this as simple as
possible and look at those features
things that are excluded are like
testing or travel or even asymptomatic
versus symptomatic you know vaccination
rate and all those things changing uh
IFR you know and
the fact that you know hospitals are
learning and improving their operations
and kind of decreasing death rate or
adherence you know you see that you know
people are getting tired of Kobe and
they want to go out that's also
important so we exclude all these things
in the estimation side we go with the
most simple
assumptions you know we for example you
know many parameters we don't estimate
them we just get them from papers so to
decrease the
um degrees of freedom that this model
have and focus on things that we really
care in terms of those you know
mechanisms that you're exploring
this is
a simple scir model as you saw in the
previous slide so if you want to show it
in a diagram what we have done to this
model is this
so we are adding one feedback
so the rate at which people are removing
from infected individuals to uh to
remove a fraction of them are dying and
you can calculate that by infection and
fatality rate you get number of death so
we want to represent that if that just
increases people will have some risk
response their perception of risk
increases that decreases their
activities and contact trade which will
decrease transmission intensity right so
for that mechanism you just take the the
calculate like death so that's delayed
death and if that's increasing based on
the equation that you see there
it's it if that increases inversely
affects transmission rate which means
that it decreases that so this is the
the main equation that we add to that
kind of conventional SAR model
and so we have a few parameters that now
we want to
um
calibration estimate them in this
analysis they would be beta not you know
the the initial
transmission intensity
Patient Zero Internet you know arrival
to the system you know when is the
disease is going to start in this region
and uh and other factors you know like
um
time that it takes for people to adjust
their risk perception so that lag to
death what is the delay for that which
can be different for different societies
in terms of a stage resetting again you
know we try to be very simple there are
more Advanced Techniques and and we
didn't do that so we went with a very
heuristic uh and and and cheap in terms
of computation
um that you know when we are projecting
a trend at the time of projection we are
considering you know the error at the
date of projection you know whatever
death today is you know if our model is
uh predicting a little bit less or a
little bit High we try to
um correct for that error but then the
rest of the simulation goes as it was
um
working
let's look at the performance of this
simple model so remember that all these
61 models in in the covet Hub they are
very Advanced and very good quality
models many of them are high quality
models and are developed by a very good
modeler so there are so many kind of
interesting features and so many
achievements there what we want to do
here is just to look at like how this
model is
um that is learning from those models
and capturing the essential kind of
useful mechanisms that those have can it
really kind of in performance also show
it performance as comparable
Wendy project so we use uh past you know
that duration of time in our projections
of use like past data and then project
and and then you know in the same time
we can also calculate the error that we
have in our projection because things
have happened right so at the time of
projection we are not using any future
data but we start projecting and then we
calculate the error so what would have
been our error if this was our
projections so we do that for 57 regions
in the United States and in this picture
adds up all the projections so in the
first glance it it looks like the simple
model can create oscillation in data
it's not perfect there are places that
you know in those red circles show time
of projections again just examples
so we can create oscillations with this
and sometimes you know as kind of error
is bigger than expected but overall you
see the patterns
then we calculate errors on projection
Horizon so we have done all these
projections with the model for different
regions let's just add up all errors per
capita and compare the performance that
you would get from this model with other
models and the model that is hard to
beat is covet cdc's covet Hub
um
ensemble projection so a fascinating
thing about cdc's covet hot is that
um
if you if you get all this data and look
at the median of
um
of projections you actually get a pretty
good prediction and that's the blue line
here so it appears that this simple
model can do a better job that hard to
beat Ensemble model in this um in this
group of models which was very
interesting so when you saw that this
model does a pretty good job in terms of
projection and the error is lower then
you started
um turning off all these features and
see which one is actually helping us
so first we turned off the effect of
weather is that helping us that's
marginally helping us and as you see
there is a uh there's uh there is a
graph that is you know has a higher
error or still better than the Ensemble
model but um but you know adding bitter
effect is marginally helping us State
resetting was helping in short-term
forecast but not in long-term forecasts
so that's kind of taking care of the
early errors
but what was the most benefit uh
beneficial feature of this model was
that feedback loop so the worst case
here that you see with the line and star
on it is our model when you turn off the
uh response the behavioral response and
that and you suddenly get a huge error
worse than most models and More Than The
Ensemble model
so apparently that feedback is what is
mainly making this work a a good
predictor then we compared the
projection of this model which each
individual model that you have in this
group of models you have
um you know you had we started the 61
models not all of them are projecting
and running and then kind of regular
basis so with this if you rank them
based on the error that you're creating
you end off of this graph and our model
is uh the black line that is bold and
you see that during the first four weeks
we are among the top 10 but then after a
while it moves higher and provides you
know as the second
um in projection the the one that is uh
constantly higher is a very good model
has you know capturing many details many
interesting details about the spread of
the diseases computationally way more
advanced and has much more detail but
importantly that's the one that has the
feedback so it's the one that was
assuming that if in projection
projecting death number of death passes
some threshold in the future again there
will be some interventions from the
government so that's the model that
actually is doing a great job in this
set
use all other measures again to compute
our model with with these models and
this is
error that each model is creating in
comparison to the constant model that I
said at the beginning that you know
assumes
um death as as constant you see that you
know there are several models that are
doing better than that model and
um and um but you know that model is not
also a necessarily bad model and and I
will mention the the reason that that's
doing
um an interesting performance
so the point here is that mechanistic
models you know
when you narrow down to
um
more kind of important structures and
avoid overfitting it helps you
simple model is helping here so this is
the lesson that we are learning from
this analysis and
what is important in expanding sqr
models is the feedback loop not
necessarily the compartments so most
focus is around
increasingly compartments increasing the
details in in compartmental models
however many times you get the most
benefit by including
behavioral impact how people are
responding to change in state variables
and that suddenly gives you
um and improves your models you know we
learn other things in this analysis like
how you can get wrong conclusion if you
just focus on one region projecting one
region or projecting at one time period
or projecting only for one
um one wave of the disease these are
these you know from data analysis
perspective it is very important to have
a big sample of regions to have a long
sample of um
of data points in terms of like
different waves of the disease you know
sometimes you're good at in one way but
not in the other one so we should all
expand these data source data um
extension and that will help you to have
to really help you know what makes a
Model A Better model
so let me just get back to the model
this was the simplest model that you can
have you know kind of conventional model
this is what we add
this is the behavioral response that you
are adding to this model making that
data endogenous so how important this
model is I just focused on forecasting
but it appears that this behavioral
feedback has many more benefits it's not
just forecasting it can help you in in
in many directions and it can provide
unique insights about several puzzles
that have been dealing during the
pandemic and I want to kind of briefly
mention that the art all documented in
this commentary in
um in bmj uh Global health so if we call
that feedback loop a risk driven
response so the assumption is that as
death increases people to receive higher
risk and they respond on that changes
the spread of the disease if you include
that it can explain several puzzles one
of them is Convergence of reproduction
number to one so this is one of the
interesting observations that some of us
had
when you look at the data points of the
spread of the disease across different
nations across different regions one of
the interesting thing and challenging
thing is that you see that these res are
all around one you know just uh
ignoring the first few months of the
pandemic which was at the beginning and
our zero was high and the disease was
spreading after a while R is converging
around one and many people actually
misinterpreted that as heard immunity
early on you know we are we are we are
finishing with the disease but that
wasn't the case there was this
convergence to one and the question was
why this is happening and it is not just
the average re you know if you look at
countries each kind of then we looked at
that like about 140 countries their
average remain between 0.9 and 1.1 so it
is not changing that much why is that
happening you know why are e converged
to one why that equilibrium emerged
so that can be explained by this
feedback remember that when re
reproduction number is above one that
means that the spread of the disease
continues to increase
right so if the number of cases are
increasing and that
corresponds to increasing number of
death
at some point eventually people will say
well this is getting out of hand you
should do something right right and then
they do sufficient reaction that's the
point that they are decreasing re until
re becomes below 1.
so re cannot be above one for a long
time at some point we will have a
behavioral reaction but what if our ego
is very low if our ego is very low then
cases Decline and Decline and Decline
and at some point people will say what
is the point of all these social
distancing this is very costly and I'm
tired of that and I want to go and
interact with people so re can't go very
low either and if it goes very low again
people will interact and will increase
that above so in this feedback loop is
resulting in convergence of re21 without
necessarily actually resulting inherit
immunity so it's not because we are
running out of
um susceptible individuals but because
people are adjusting their behaviors
based on cases or based on risk
perception
so this is the first puzzle the second
is about the waves of the pandemic you
know it is a good question that why do
we have these ways in the disease where
are they coming from why do we have
oscillation
if you think about this feedback that
was introduced here from a system
science perspective or from control
theory perspective it is a negative
feedback it's the balancing feedback
loop and in that theory we know that
for to have oscillation you have to have
a negative feedback loop with at least
two stock variables or two level
variables to create oscillation it is
necessary not sufficient but you need to
have that so this mechanism is creating
and can create oscillation and we
observe that in our simulation too
so this is one of the reasons for
observe waves of the pandemic early on
again you know if you read the papers
during the pandemic many people were
kind of trying to find reasons of
oscillations and usually the hypotheses
are around waning immunity which is
correct reigning immunity can create
oscillation but then not
quickly I mean it will take to see that
pattern and the effect and the in
creating waves it takes I know the rent
the the duration of uh or the period of
oscillation that you would see from
waning immunity was not matching the
waves that we were seeing from covid-19
especially early on in the pandemic or
new variants they can create
oscillations seasonal patterns can
create oscillation and other behavioral
mechanisms so this was an additional
explanation about how you get waves in
in a pandemic
the third one is that you see mortality
variants in different countries why
different countries have different
um different depth and that can't be
easily explained by many other variables
and but
consider that again feedback loop
so the question is that at what level of
depth you will be convinced to have
stronger measures to control the society
if culturally and if economically we
have different
thresholds or reaction to number yeah
that's the resulting variation in
um in the level of the level of
mortality that you've seen in these
cases so my colleague has written a
paper on this and they analyze and show
that there's a good correlation between
how responsive the society or that
region is to to death and number of
death that they have so that better
explains the correlation
this four item is the one that I
presented today and how it helps
enhancing forecasting or the puzzle of
why forecasting models are failing
the fifth puzzle was about vaccine
prioritization you may remember that you
know many models kind of argued that
um given the high mortality of elderly
it might be optimal to start vaccination
from elderly and these are coming again
from models that don't have this
behavioral feedback loop there so if you
expand our idea our model to models of
different age groups and how the
behavioral feedback there but consider
that different aging groups have
different behavioral responses because
their risk of dying is different
then suddenly your optimal solution for
vaccination changes so it is not just
the fact that younger individuals may
have more interactions but also the fact
that their responsiveness to death might
be different than
um all elderly because they are less
likely to die I mean they have less risk
in as related to uh to covet
um 19. and the intuition here is is
interesting just assume that you have
two groups one is
um
less responsive to
um kind of
overall risk one is more responsive if
you are vaccinating the one that is more
responsive right first then the disease
is still spreading and and the death is
decreasing the ones that are more
responsive are high risk so if the death
overall will will decrease which would
increase everybody's interaction too but
if you start from vaccinating the ones
that are less likely to die you're
actually building a herd immunity and
it's still the one that are more
responsive are have a higher risk
perception so they are taking care of
themselves while you are also building
hair in unity and suddenly
um you you end up with an optimal
solution that uh the society you know in
general is is building paired immunity
and the cases are declining
finally the concept of endemic that
these days especially you are thinking
about it so what is this and then make
you know where that can happen you know
what what is the meaning of endemic
and and if you think again in terms of
the feedback loop that was introduced so
it it means that the risks are declining
or our perception of risk is has
declined so it is related to reduced
number of cases as everybody is thinking
about that it is related to lower
fatality rate which is about vaccination
about treatment but it is also about
tolerance of risk and how people are and
kind of
responding to the risks that they see
or in simple word endemic is when people
say that the risk is not
big enough for me to change my behavior
and I can go to the normal life so the
risk is when this feedback loop loses
its power
and that's when we come to the normal
life so the implication here is a state
of endemic is an epidemiological and
disease-related construct but it's also
a behavioral construct so it also
relates to how we perceive risks so it
is different for different regions
because of how the disease is present
but also it is different because of how
people of different you know different
regions may have different responses
different sensitivities to the risk so
it is also a behavioral construct that
you see here
so this is my presentation thank you
I'll be happy to answer questions
Naveed thank you so much that was
fascinating
um
I had I have several questions here so
um
firstly clearly scr R models are going
to be insufficient because as you
rightly point out they don't really
factor into the behavior of the
individual elements that go into the
modeling the thing one being trying to
model is the interaction between the the
the people or you know the the sample
subjects I guess that are being
represented in the model
um but it doesn't take into account
their behavior and yet of course the
scrr models it also involve first order
partial differential equations or
differential equations I guess they're
not partial they're just ordinarily
differential equations are some of your
modeling is it do you feel that it the
one of the net results of this is that
those models should be kind of looked at
and revised to be made higher order to
take into account higher order
differential factors which might be
better reflective of behavior
so that that's a very good point
it is this is true that seirs uh have
limited you know capacity to to
represent you know the spread of the
disease especially when human behavior
is important which was the case of covet
19. so the question is that how you can
expand that so you have a model of
disease in the spread of the disease but
there is also human change in human
behavior one approach was that people
use the same scir and for human behavior
they eat data like they get Mobility
data and they feed it to the model
changing transmission rate that's okay
for fitting the past data it is not okay
for projecting because you don't know
how people will change their Mobility
you don't know how people will change
their behavior you don't have data for
their future
all right so that's the limitation that
they have when you use scir and feed
Behavior as an exogenous variable or as
time series as Mobility time series
which is the very common approach these
days
another way to fix and extend this area
as you were going in that direction is
to add a modeling feature to that and
model human behavior so this
presentation that I had
was the first step modeling just risk
response so that's a very simple
response that you know human can have
the assumption is that death Rises I
feel higher risk perception and I
decrease my activity and that that
declines I will increase my activity
because I have a lower risk perception
that's the simplest one but if I want to
kind of build on your ideas there are
there are other things that you can add
and get more and more complicated models
for example kobit fatigue or adherence
fatigue that means that you know as you
decrease your activities you're
accumulating this social or
psychological construct which is fatigue
and you get tired and at some point you
may actually say that despite the risk I
can't do this anymore or you may say
that despite the risk I I need to earn
money so I need to work right so that
also is a behavioral or economic
construct that comes in place so yes you
know SAR models in their traditional
format are not adequate the focus on
just expanding compartments is not
helping to focus on including data
exogenously to the models is not helping
the way to move forward is to build
coupled disease Behavior models where
you are actually modeling human behavior
as a function of different variables in
your system I imagine that those models
would become non-linear and be very
interesting mathematically to examine
the behavior of and one of the things
which I also was fascinated by with your
modeling that you've just presented is
that you've included the weather as a
potential variable
um and it was just reminded me of the
old joke that lots of people talk about
the weather but nobody's doing anything
about it in your in your case you're
able to go and put the put the weather
in as a factor and see whether or not it
changes or take the weather out I'm
curious if there are other weather-like
variables that may affect human behavior
that might also be suitable for
inclusion in models like this and I was
thinking of like the stock market if we
were all locked down but the stock
market was just going you know crazy and
you know the Dow Jones Industrial index
was you know at all-time highs it might
affect our individual behavior I'm
curious if you have given any thought to
other weather-like models that might be
important
and that's also very interesting point
um
my first thought would be that the
difference between weather and and and
the stock market is the same thing that
you said that we we don't do anything
about weather right we talk about it and
you know I I know that you know even
weather is endogenous with all these
global warming issues so we are we are
changing the weather too but at least in
the time Horizon of our analysis whether
it's exogenous
but the stock market economy is getting
feedback from the interactions that we
have in the society and and the state of
the disease is influencing our economic
activity so a good model would be a
coupled disease economy model that would
include this as a feedback loop
that would be that would be very
exciting to see again that would
probably add non-linearities to the to
the system that would mean how you model
it would make it very interesting make
interesting predictions that's for sure
but on the other hand it may also be
sensitive to initial conditions which is
kind of again where there could be a lot
of science to be explored one of the
things which I I think that you touched
on which I thought was really
interesting is the the topic of
mortality of variance and just how much
mortality one is willing to accept
before there's sort of a policy either a
behavioral change at the level of the
individual or policy change at the level
of a community or a society and I'm
curious about
things that we're seeing now for example
in China where there was an initial
policy of you know zero exposure we're
not going to let anybody you know expose
anybody else and now we're seeing sort
of the the
knock-on effect of that that they waited
so long that now people who if they go
out in the world at all they're being
exposed and now you're just seeing
what's running rampant through that
Community is that something that some of
these models might have been able to
forecast
so that that's a very important point
and again it is about the complexity of
the situation that we are dealing with
so on one hand we know that
um responsiveness to the state of
disease is important if you are more
responsive
you can better control the disease the
spread of the disease but on the other
hand
and one thing that is underestimated is
that you are accumulating adherence
fatigue right and at some point that
fatigue will kind of
um pass its own threshold and then we
cannot tolerate it anymore and we want
to go out right we will say well this is
the two extreme policy you want to go
out and in that instead now the question
is that are we vaccinated enough or
dealing with this new condition you know
very balanced in our NPI and
pharmaceutical interventions all
together right when that thing happens
re in vaccine wise are we prepared to
deal with that and then with new
variants you know we all know that
all these behavioral reactions decrease
the spread of disease by some percentage
right if you decrease it by like 30 or
40 percent and you end up with a
mutation that is way more kind of has a
much higher or not than
the the level of kind of control that we
have might not be sufficient for the new
variants so there are all these
complexities that come and play a role
here
absolutely Navid what are some final
thoughts on the role for data science in
trying to do forecasting to draw from
data to apply it to in this case
epidemiological Trends and human
behavior where what do data scientists
need to know in order to be able to
utilize tools like this and to to work
in this space
um I think there's a there's a huge
value in in using
um kind of benefiting from what is
emerging so obviously with these new
opportunities to have access to huge
data sources you know this um covet
models that we use and access that we
had to always and availability of data
these are all important so I think the
role of data science is is increasing
but personally you know as a modeler I I
like
to have these two hand in hand and use
data to improve models and use models to
have a better sense of what type of data
I should look at so kind of rather than
just using Computing approaches and
looking it as a black box I like to see
it mechanistically I like to think about
Rules of Nature and like how things are
connected and how things evolve and then
use that when I'm exploring the
questions so there was a great
opportunity to use data but also we
should open our eyes and look at
mechanisms and and and and systems in
white box way too and see how the Logics
of the system is working the other
lesson that I learned in this paper and
actually the credit goes to my co-author
is that if you expand the regions and
expand your sample in different
directions you know expand the regions
expand the time Horizon so you try to
have many many different conditions in
your test that really helps you to to be
more confident in the results that
you're finding so not being
narrow-minded but kind of extending it
to different regions and that's now
possible because of all these
advancement in data science so you don't
have to just take a simple Trend and
from a country and then look at that or
symbol you know time period you can do
your analysis use using a very large
sample of
cases models regions and and kind of be
more
confident in the results that you're
finding or make your results more valid
thank you so much this has really been
wonderful um a very impressive amount of
work I I really have enjoyed chatting
with you so thank you so much and thank
you to everyone who's uh watching on
YouTube and who's joined us here on zoom
and uh we wish you a very good weekend
and we'll see you next week thank you
again Navid